[Music]
in gross baby news oh no another way is
it gonna be one of those dear [ __ ]
what was that dear Brian remember that
ghost appear oh yeah David David Jerry
anything with David Dunn scary oh why
thank you submitted by Joel Malian ghost
hunter yes Gary we have a lot of jobs
Dena coaster people a woman reveals she
is in a relationship with a ghost she
met whoa what a loser she's watching
that old movie with Whoopi Goldberg
ghosts ghosts
oh that's a good movie with Denny more
dude
Whoopi Goldberg is in it yeah Whoopi
Goldberg in a movie she's better Demi
Moore was so [ __ ] hot in that movie
it's like insane you're like with Whoopi
Goldberg
that was the best 15 minutes no but that
was the highlight for me Whoopi knows
she's in it for no but if you were to
combine all of her screen times she's
called me in the mood for a grand total
of 15 minutes that's true the [ __ ]
ceramic scene and the ceramic scene and
Patrick Stewart and I saw this plane
when he's making the call
great great I would much rather watch a
girl have sex with the ghost on a
surveillance camera then a guy oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] talking about cuz the guy
watch a girl Jill off video than a guy
jerking off like yeah me too man people
like the other one some people like
coffee some people I teased affair but
he says [ __ ] robot I don't know
what's going on I get it yeah knows
you're a [ __ ] thought process you're
in [ __ ] left field away from the rest
of the [ __ ] population baby excuse me
I typically understand most people's
thought process you just don't
understand mine I would rather watch a
girl blowing a guy than a guy blowing a
guy that's different
we're talking about we're talking about
ghosts [ __ ] this mystery I'd rather
get my dick sucked by a girl and suck my
own dick [ __ ] is different okay my
bad forget it
golf's [ __ ] a girl is like doggystyle
right it's just pretending a ghost is
like boning her the dude has his dick
out and he's pretending to be proving
our point what dick going like this you
just supported our point gave us a
picture of this ghost taking form you
know okay is if it's a hot ghost year
that takes a human like a human form
then it's like I could see that but if
it's invisible [ __ ] dick thrusting in
the air yeah although I saw that I saw
both points you see what I'm saying
I'm trying easy points to recognize
though so sorry no you don't not easy
points because you also didn't take it
into account the wind that was happening
what I actually like mostly wind around
there she liked about this back down I
actually like that you won't back down
on this I actually pick these [ __ ]
stubborn do I'm not stubborn you know
that's more example I'm gonna just drink
this yes I thank you for the funny
imagery though
what's this ghost what's the deal so
this woman she's from the UK she's 30
years old she's a spiritual guidance
counselor and she claims to have
encounters which is unemployed yeah is
what she really are she's hella ballin
psychic yeah she says that for the last
11 years she's been in relationships
with 20 different ghostly lovers what a
player I wonder how the breakups look
like you know the break-up she's
throwing plates against the wall and
[ __ ] yelling at the wall does she have a
ghost STD she says grandma let me show
you guys a clip of her on this show
what kind of argument she has with their
[ __ ] ghost boyfriends what the [ __ ]
is a ghost st oh you know be I don't
know like [ __ ] ghost media or
something see is the [ __ ] Ghostbuster
symbol and [ __ ] I hope one of her
boyfriends was abusive and then I'm the
ghost just beat her up so she's just
like hook up house with surveillance
cameras and this would be a dope show
yeah what would creep me the [ __ ] out I
would love to see their arguments right
you little
look at this dress you're dead I'm so
sorry I'd really didn't meet bothers you
I know you can't come back to life I
just don't know I said that you're sexy
when she gets bent over and there's all
the drapes and the curtain is flat
because it ghosts the ghosts wins dude
what when ghosts come in it when ghosts
come it's like this what are they gonna
walk by that this god that's how I can
say that no not like calm but like when
they just when they appear go away they
appear thing all right I buy it
thank you thanks Steve I wish that you
had a [ __ ] jacket on and you said
like ghost expert I wish I have a bunch
of dust on this table so I could show
you what a ghost Landing looks like you
buy what you have as much credibility
right now as this lady yeah yeah yeah
yeah so she says that she's trying to
have a ghost baby because this last
lover of hers I'm pretty serious he's
been coming in her you know how she's
starting all this [ __ ] so she was
engaged to a human and when she she
moved into their new place and that's
what she felt this presence and she
started cheating on her fiance with his
ghost and then he found apparently she's
saying but he didn't see anything he's
like what do you doing she's just
[ __ ] dies down there what the [ __ ]
were you naked in before he's like oh
you walked in he's like I can't believe
you [ __ ] cheat on you know the ghosts
right like this no I'm not here he knew
it was just weird like he probably
walked in the room she says like but
[ __ ] with the leg spread she'll you I'm
so sorry it's like why
I know but then all of a sudden he felt
a goose by him and then the door slammed
behind ya he's like who was that well
she was saying that the fiance said that
the ghost appeared to him to get the boy
the fiancee to leave her the guy said
that he corroborated that well that's
what she said oh she said she's saying
that the fiance saw the dude because the
ghost was so in love with her that she
was trying to kick this dude out and
they were together for about three years
okay okay ghost was she's with I'm in
know I'm in show you guys this clip of
her describing sex so she looks like
[Music]
I love how the hosts are taking this
[ __ ] like so you have to
it's like art Bell used to interview
people the craziest [ __ ] and like he
talked a guy who's like he's like my
kitchens alive it's a living being and
it [ __ ] every time I walk into it it
can breathe and I talk to it and our
fellows are some following yes yes and
and and does your kitchen speak multiple
languages sir like you just have to
accept it if you're gonna interview
these people yes man you exactly it's
better called they're asking her did you
come and she like he's like in mystic
ghost to come to and then she's like oh
no he doesn't like coming inside me
likes coming a little bit my face she's
like she's like he came on my face this
morning kids Yuto and does he have a
really cold PB oh it's energy [ __ ]
its energy [ __ ] okay
she's don't think you feel the weight
but it's weightless yep it's weight with
those weightless has weird hmm yeah but
I mean do she's literally the ghost town
[ __ ] where's her GoFundMe I want a
paper she's a ghost [ __ ] she's a ghost
dude she [ __ ] how many goes so far 20
20 of them and she was married so you
had to break up so how did the other
ghost fights go down you know do they
all just keep [ __ ] going to her house
and then they have like ghost parties
are like yo this human [ __ ] she'll let
you [ __ ] up did you even research this
article at all I haven't been able to
tell you know anything cuz she [ __ ] two
species it's inner spirit [ __ ] yeah
oh you've heard of people having ten
tantric sex oh yeah what is no it's in
the real world what sighs I think
between humans do like you're not even
it is within your mind it's like you're
not touching though right or you're not
physically if that call had sex
remember the Coneheads old ass referal
yeah that's good would you have sex with
a ghost if
gia would you have sex with a ghost oh
yeah Bart would you have sex with a
ghost
yep hey David would you have sex with a
ghost what is it go slip plane free hot
girls weirdoes that's the back end for
the ghost in what I'm just gonna come
out of nowhere gated Jo would you have
sex with the ghost not thousand trillion
percent yes I would do it because it's a
different species it's a different is
that what you would say about a dog well
no that dog is a lower subspecies
because having a ghost is like an
advanced species what about if it's a
ghost dog anything that's above me on
the food chain how about that
the both is not a buggy I think they are
dirt I think they're multi-dimensional
being yeah could be in our dimension and
then the extra tips so you're telling me
you [ __ ] alien hell yeah I'm
especially [ __ ] you would like this
blimey type of alien especially if it's
a sign retail oh yeah you just [ __ ]
sold away vaginas are pretty slimy sorry
vaginas alien green oh is like something
disgusting nothing says aliens look like
that alright you species yes yes that's
why I mean I didn't say that they are
everyone says the degree makes me feel
weird
I never seen a fine-ass alien he never
played I played back you come back
you'll come back not be sad
[Music]